considering how singular Joaquin
Phoenix's interpretation of the Joker
promises to be it's probably a good idea
to know a little bit about the
characters long history to fully
appreciate what's different about his
depiction here's everything you need to
know before watching 2019 s Joker since
his debut in 1940s Batman number one the
Joker has been Batman's most popular and
enduring arch-nemesis as a result he's
appeared opposite every big-screen
version of the Caped Crusader's
adventures since 1966 is Batman the
movie while the characters popularity
has remained consistent the different
cinematic Joker's have taken a very
different approach to the tone of the
character the version played by Cesar
Romero was a perfect fit for the campy
relatively light-hearted world imagined
by the TV show he was portrayed as more
of a giggling over-the-top bank robber
than anything else when the Joker
returned to theaters in Tim Burton's
1989 Batman film with Jack Nicholson
under the makeup he was played as
something a little more like a murderous
performance artists he was a hitman for
the mob with a thing for playing cards
right from the beginning of the film and
even killed Bruce Wayne's parents in
that version of Batman's origin story
but as dip into the acid gave him a
whole new perspective he not only took
over Gotham City's crime families for
himself he also plotted to kill everyone
in the city dosing them with poisonous
gases his masterpiece
Batman the Animated Series hit
television screens in 1992 and the
following year saw the theatrical
release of an animated movie mask of the
phantasm in both the show and the film
the Joker was played by Mark Hamill who
might be best known from his starring
role as Luke Skywalker in a little-known
independent film called Star Wars
Hamill's version of the character was
been loved by fans and he kept the role
in various animated shows and video
games through today despite flirting
with retirement from the part after
Batman Arkham City 2008 brought us to
dark nights and Heath Ledger's
unforgettable Academy award-winning
performance this time unlike Burton and
Nicholson stake The Joker had no origin
story and even told conflicting versions
of his history to different characters
throughout the film
my father was a drinker he built himself
as an agent of chaos with intricate
clockwork plans that were designed to
destroy any sense of morality the Batman
had returned to his city with the launch
of DC's movie universe we got another
version of the Joker in Suicide Squad
which saw Jared Leto apparently going
full method actor in order to embrace
the Joker's sinister personality in this
tank he was a heavily tattooed
unpredictable crime boss with a gift for
manipulating people like a sidekick
Harley Quinn a character who had
originally appeared in the animated
series and rose to incredible popularity
in the decade since with that many
different portrayals not to mention all
of the different interpretations of the
Joker that have appeared in comic books
over the past 80 years the idea that any
single actor could be the only true
Joker is as insane as the character
himself even with that in mind though
Joaquin Phoenix's portrayal in the
Joker's first-ever solo film promises to
be a pretty big departure from what
we've seen before one of the first
questions fans were asking when Warner
Brothers announced that Phoenix had been
cast as the Joker was what happened to
Jared Leto at one point there were no
fewer than six Joker related films in
development with Leto still attached for
some of them where the filmmakers just
replacing Leto and being coy about it's
the answer Leto's Joker and Phoenix's
Joker aren't the same guy the Joker of
2019 will not be part of the DC's movie
universe it's a standalone film and has
nothing to do with Suicide Squad 2017
Justice League twenty20 ones the Batman
or any other DC films that actually may
have something to do with why Phoenix
accepted the lead and Joker he came
close to playing dr. strange turned down
the role of Superman's nemesis Lex
Luthor in audition for the part of the
Red Skull in 2011's Captain America the
First Avenger but never wound up
appearing in any of those movies the
major difference between those roles and
the role of Joker is that signing up for
Lex or strange would have obligated
Phoenix to appear in other movies with
the new Joker film being built as a
standalone character driven drama rather
than franchise blockbuster Phoenix can
play the character without signing on
for a sprawling series of superhero
movies one of the things that makes this
Joker distinct from most other versions
is that we're actually learning the name
he was born with
Arthur Fleck it isn't the first time a
writer is given the Clown Prince of
Crime a proper first and last name in
the Gotham TV series The Joker is
Jeremiah Valeska in Tim Burton's Batman
Joker is known as Jack Napier a suitably
comic book II pun on jackanapes another
word for a fool my number-one guy in
most other versions including the comics
Canon and the award-winning version in
the Dark Knight however the Joker goes
unnamed even in Batman The Killing Joke
a 1988 graphic novel by Alan Moore and
Brian Bolland that includes the Joker
origin story in all of the flashbacks to
Joker's past we never learned so much as
his first name we all know Joaquin
Phoenix will be Joker's lead though some
fans theorize will eventually learn that
this particular clown isn't the real
Joker he won't be on the screen alone
though and there are plenty of other
interesting names as part of the cast
appearing as Thomas Wayne is Brett Cohen
a distinguished character actor with a
long career in Hollywood beginning in
the 80s what's interesting about his
appearance here is that Joker will be
Cullen's second Batman related film he
plays a congressman in 2012's Dark
Knight Rises frances conroy plays flex
ailing mother penny she's perhaps best
remembered for her role as Ruth Fisher
in HBO's Six Feet Under
but she also has a surprising Bat
related film connection she played the
small but crucial part of Ophelia in
2004's legendarily bad cat woman we also
see sassy beats briefly in the Joker
trailer fans will likely remember beats
his performances Domino in 2018 s
Deadpool 2 but in Joker she plays Sophie
du monde a single mother and flex love
interests one of the most interesting
casting choices is that of Robert De
Niro as talk-show host
Marie Franklin fans and critics are
speculating Joker will in many ways be
strongly influenced by Martin Scorsese's
1982 darkly satirical the king of comedy
De Niro plays a struggling mentally ill
comic in that film just as Phoenix plays
one and Joker the young Bruce Wayne we
see Fleck forcing the smile with his
fingers in the trailer is played by
Dante Pereira Olsen and it won't be the
first time he's worked with Phoenix
Olson was and you were never really here
where he played the younger version of
Phoenix's character another mentally ill
man living with his elderly mother from
what we've seen in the trailer Joker
doesn't seem like an adaptation of any
single comic book story however there
are glimmers of inspiration from
specific comics and at least one aspect
of Joker is similar to one of the most
influential Joker stories of all time
written by Alan Moore famous for
Watchmen V for Vendetta and other
groundbreaking comics of the 80s and
drawn by Brian Bolland The Killing Joke
is memorable for many reasons one of
which is the origin story given to the
Joker we never learn his name but the
younger Joker is an aspiring stand-up
comic who can't get a break no one
laughs at his jokes he isn't making any
money and his young wife has a baby on
the way
desperate he agrees to go on a heist
with some crooks and falls into a bed of
chemicals that turn him into the villain
we all know like this unnamed young
Joker
Arthur Fleck seems to be a failed comic
but that may be where the similarities
end
rather than the classic comics origin of
a fall into a vat of chemicals Fleck
seems to be a man driven to and beyond
the brink by the madness of society
using makeup to adopt the Joker's
persona much like Ledger's version did
the other major influence on Joker
doesn't come from the comics page
instead the visuals we see in the
trailer are heavily influenced by the
king of comedy while it's not as
well-known as hits like taxi driver or
Goodfellas the 1983 collaboration
between Martin Scorsese and Robert De
Niro became a cult classic for its
portrayal of a struggling comedian who
develops a disturbing fixation on a
Johnny Carson s talk-show hosts De Niro
stars is failing comic Rupert Pupkin
while Jerry Lewis plays the very
successful Jerry Langford while he
doesn't dress up like a super villain
like Fleck pumpkin is portrayed as being
mentally ill and the film ends with some
ambiguity about whether or not the
viewer is experiencing actual events or
pumpkins delusions Joker is even set in
the early 80s just like the king of
comedy the influence isn't just evident
from the trailer however Scorsese
himself was originally set to be
executive producer for Joker but left
the project due to scheduling issues
regardless the final project seems to
have his fingerprints all over it
moviegoers expecting to see
Dark Knight's showing up in Joker to
face off with his nemesis are bound to
be disappointed but the film isn't
entirely free of Batman we're just
seeing him long before he decides to
dress up as a bat and spend his evenings
fighting criminals given that we're
getting a young Bruce Wayne and a
prominent role for his dad it's possible
that Joker might include the murder that
kicks off Batman's own origin story but
whether or not that what actually
happened remains to be seen it's clear
however that no matter what happens to
Thomas and Martha their son will spend
this film a long way from donning his
familiar comic book costume Joker is no
superhero movie instead the cast and
director Todd Phillips have spoken of
the movie as a far more intimate
character peace and a study of mental
illness rather than an action film about
a killer clown squirting acid at cops
out of flowers on his lapels surrounded
by henchmen it will however take place
in Batman's fictional hometown of Gotham
City complete with some familiar
landmarks although it seems to be a more
realistic one than what we might be used
to the trailer has a few shots outside
and inside Arkham State Hospital which
is a much more real-world version of
Arkham Asylum than we've seen in other
Batman media in the comics cartoons and
video games
Arkham often appears as an impossible
nightmare that looks like a gothic
mansion that you would expect to show up
in an old Dracula movie the Arkham of
Joker looks more like what you'd find in
the real world it's a State Hospital
rather than an asylum a term that fell
out of favor decades ago flek appears to
be walking there across the city streets
whereas in most portrayals it's out in
the middle of the wilderness past
imposing wrought iron gates Phillips
wants us to see Fleck in the same cold
sterile uncaring bureaucracy the
mentally ill have to navigate in our own
world rather than a place that looks
like an immense haunted house with
prison cells designed for crocodile men
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite DC characters are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]